ils ont joué au football malgré leur
handicap mental samedi 23 octobre cette
équipe des illuminés de leur ont
participé à un tournoi de futsal
organisé au gymnase lui quand de mantes
la jolie ça représente beaucoup de
progrès de
leur présence pendant nos collègues j'ai
bien aimé ça m'a fait me dépenser
après ces deux tournois ou quoi sous
verre au total ce deuxième rendez-vous a
permis à plus de 60 joueurs de pratiquer
leur passion ils étaient trois fois plus
nombreux que lors de la précédente
édition les matchs se sont déroulés de
13h30 à 17h chaque partie duré dix
minutes objectif prendre du plaisir il
n'y a pas grand chose qui change on va
être beaucoup plus souple en termes
d'arbitrages et
par rapport à chaque individualité
en gros
on peut on peut siffler certaines choses
à d'autres personnes qu'on connaît où on
va être un peu plus exigeant une
personne qui a une déficience un peu
plus profonde ou marquer on va être
beaucoup plus souple sur les règles on
pourra laisser un peu plus jouer donc
c'est vrai que c'est pas 100% les règles
du futsal mais on garde quand même cette
souplesse parce qu'on n'est pas c'est
pas le championnat du monde la
compétition a finalement été remporté
par l'équipe de mantes-la-jolie les
organisateurs ont déjà donné rendez vous
pour l'année prochaine la troisième
édition de ce tournoi de futsal de sport
adapté devrait de nouveau être programmé
en octobre